[Music]
by hiding with this is the slimmest
building in the world what does it take
from an engineering perspective to
actually construct something like this
it's a combination of very advanced
Windtunnel testing that wasn't available
a few years ago okay much stronger
concrete than was available a few years
ago and a number of other engineering
factors it really turned out to be this
amazing juxtaposition of old and new as
we stand here and you look up you have
this amazing restored copper lantern
that we refabricated off original
drawings and then this amazing
contemporary tower behind it so it's
that old and new play that we were very
excited about as developers you don't
get a chance to do this very often
[Music]
I'm on the 43rd floor in a twenty eight
point seven five million dollar
apartment this is 50 feet of glass on
Central Park the apartment is obviously
quite nice but the real star of the show
is the view in the kitchen when you're
you know taking a break from cooking or
watching someone cook for you you can
look out to Columbus Circle to New
Jersey all the way down Central Park to
Harlem each apartment takes up an entire
floor so when you step off the elevator
you're home the front of the apartment
is entertaining spaces the back is
bedrooms this apartment has three
bedrooms so as you walk down a hallway
that's filled with more closet space
than most New Yorkers have is living
space you go into one of the three
bedrooms where there's a marble covered
bathroom and then the bedroom itself you
have views of the Empire State Building
you can actually see the terra cotta on
the side of the facade and of course you
have views through all of southern
Manhattan I'm here in the master
bathroom next to me is a bathtub that
was custom designed for this space the
walls and floors and sinks even the
insides of the sinks are onyx
the walls are more polished the floors
are more matte if that matters and then
over here is the shower and there is a
window looking straight out across
Manhattan so even in the bathroom you've
got a view in this apartment
[Music]
I'm on the 82nd floor above all of the
residential spaces standing in front of
800 tons of steel that comprised the
toon mass damper that basically
counteracts the sway at the building now
even if this wasn't here the building
would be fine it's exclusively for
comfort and what it does is when the
building sways in one direction it moves
in the opposite direction to keep the
building as straight and steady as
possible now it's not just the steel
it's also filled with sand so this is a
colossal contraption that takes up as
you can see the entire floor of the
building so we're on the exterior moist
on the exterior of the building it's
definitely not for the faint of heart
or for anyone who has ever confronted
their own mortality because there's a
lot of [ __ ] and something
our point in year two but for a casual
visitor
I would say absolutely terrifying we're
standing in the 94 year old historic
Steinway Hall atrium which as you can
see is a pretty crazy place it's
designed to give a sense of place and
grandeur and ceremony to its original
purpose namely selling pianos and as a
result you see intricately carved marble
columns you see this plaster coffered
ceiling you see this very large mural
that's in the process of being restored
and you see it culminating into this
colossal crystal chandelier which is
hanging above the only thing that
doesn't quite make sense namely this
model of the 91 storey 111 West 57th
Street Tower which is adjacent to the
Steinway building
you